possa fregiarsi altro giorno altra vita
senza corpo oltre che tirchia gino
stento anche pigrizia io nell'armadio
cio 4 felpe da da restare in casa ecco
quattro felpe tra cui questa qui che è
da 3 è un altera felpa di sea of thieves
non so se si vede che tutta verde ed è
proprio la classica felpa natalizia che
ti metti quando vuoi stare a casa della
nonna tutto caldo è quando fa freddo mi
metto questo ragazzo ci siamo sul cloud
disco gen
credo sia svedese perché sempre al nome
di una delle sedie dell'ikea quindi non
lo so ci sono dei bambini che corrono a
caso va bene non ci aveva voglia di
farlo azioni play giochiamo hucknall dr
scorgere non va sul tasto play
adesso andato bene corrono i bambini e
io sono contento
c'è anche una narrazione in tutto questo
cosa estero del provino ever land cosa
storta cos'è ma che guance grosse che ci
hanno questi bimbi che morbidi cosa tese
ma perché una cosa è avere è un
criminale
lo facevo anch'io anzi lo faccio ancora
adesso gli avanti questo gioco si
preannuncia pazzesco amido anche il
passo mizar e il personaggio ok ti
faccio mi piaceva coveri prima dai va
bene dai party così a me con joystick e
di arrivo devo recuperare i bambini o
che ho capito per questa società taq taq
taq questa è una bicicletta c'è un
bambino qua scusi hanno preso lancia mar
fb non si possono lasciare i bambini
cos'è sta roba vi segue lo devi stare lì
devo trovare gli attimi dove sono i tuoi
fratelli grazie perché lì allora devo
lanciare qual è il problema basta a
trovarli però devo speck e c'è qualcuno
nel cestino
come si fa qua hanno aspetta forse devo
colpire il cestino con il bambino è la
madonna che dinamiche di gioco
incredibili vennero trovati due sono
proprio un baby sitter modello ma a me
se volete farvi tenere i film sono qua
io se vuoi la smettesse di infilarvi le
dita nel naso a quest'ora non ci
sarebbero di questi problemi
c'è un altro bimbo la all'aspetto la
prendiamo dopo quel neo briani qualche
c'è un'altra strada alla specie un altro
so mai cosa state facendo spiega che
cos'è sta roba
io non capisco perché questa cammina
così tra la non ha un senso da bimbo
chiamaci ne mancano 20 ce ne sono un
sacco
questo è un bimbo rosso aspetto che devo
come ci si salito lassù spiegami e wii u
na sega perché è data una facciata bravo
lento di farlo di nuovo una facciata sul
tronco allora c'è di un'ora per
recuperare un bambino ai ragazzi siamo a
7 siamo a un quarto dell'opera sono
veramente troppi basta salire sugli
alberi ma come fa la sede delle scimmie
scendete dall'albero maledizione la vita
sono otto ma poi ci saranno non ho
capito ma ci sono altri livelli o questo
è l'unico no perché ha qualcosa che
fosse buttar giù bambino sull'albero
veloce esatto hanno più bambini devono
dare ok
non è proprio e che cosa è successo
linea non è proprio mega femminile cioè
non saprei come descriverlo però vabbè
questi si stanno facendo la grigliata
vabbè dai perché vedrete ds in campeggio
forza svegliarsi barcola stravede cos'è
che peraltro non puoi non lo puoi
sbagliare non devi lanciare i bambini a
parabola perché se non riesce a
svegliare gli altri bova ben 13 ne
mancano boneva eccone uno che lancio era
amico mio
davis e devi scendere scendi scendi di
qua porca latte non riescono anche a
prenderlo questo è proprio difficile si
incastra denutrito c'è un pallonetto sul
bambino allora perfetto lo stop buttato
giù
mancano 10 vedo che ce ne stanno un po
laggiù non so se sono tutti
effettivamente ora andiamoci madonna che
gioco incredibile soggiogandoli questo
ed ex trending sembra un po i said sto
gioco non so perché se fosse in 2d
sarebbe inside è bello come sono tutti
ordinatissimi si muovono tutti alla
perfezione 17 mancano ne mancano e
quando sono bravi in matematica ne
mancano 8 c'è uno qua nascosto contavo
visto pirla abili c'è un'altra strada
che non avevo visto allora ne mancano 6
questo sta pescando nel pozzo non so
cosa dire quasi quasi ti ci butto
proprio altro il pozzo è vuoto c'è
l'erba ragazzi non sto riuscendo a
recuperare il bambino questo qua
all'angolo
porca vacca non riesco neanche a lande
anche lanciando i bambini funziona è
uscita la nuova patch di ford knight
saranno questo avrebbe dovuto funzionare
invece non si vede che si è incastrato
nelle texture questo bambino non si
sveglia
vabbè non importa andiamo avanti
chissenefrega veloci non lo sveglio lo
sveliamo dopo questo rilanciamo 26 altri
bambini
svegliatevi 23 marca vacca di essere
proprio preciso alright 23 24 e 25 ce
n'è uno in più allora quello non era non
era mio quell'ora aggiuntivo
ok va bene allora niente sono 25 quindi
sono tutti ce n'era uno in più dei a de
ceglie lanciati peggio bimbi questo
proprio non ne vuole sapere
chesta un albero là dietro a meda io
basta tanto vergogna dormi fai quello
che vuoi
l'abbiamo 25 vanno bene così vagono noto
con piacere che c'è una recinzione
aperta con su scritto click the skies
drop gect va bene c'è un altro
ma per come arriva ma certo che poi
anche dormire per terra 0 che fa sulle
rocce che mori però vabbè ne ho 31
l'importante questo ora che possiamo
tornare non mi ricordo la strada per
tornare indietro un po grave questa cosa
vorrà quello che sta esattamente dietro
di meco ecc al bastone che lo meno così
come se niente fosse proprio lui è fiero
di tutto questo va beh guarda quanti
parachì fila ma cosa cosa sto giocando
gesù li ho tutti e cioè tranne uno però
ciglio
sono 31 bimbi altri li ho trovati
omaggio a posto esce proprio la storia
che continua ma dai
all'ultimo era lì 15 57 di auto
personale 16 e non c'è campo ho avuto
un'idea
chissà che idea incredibile vediamo e
video remi contro te
questo c'è te li sei infilati nei
capelli cos'è successo
no non credo ho capito cosa sta
succedendo ai presidi tutti in braccio
li è presi
[Musica]
ma cosa
cosa è successo come finì così sofia a
non sta tornando indietro a piedi e non
capivo puoi prenderne anche uno alla
volta cioè non tutti quanti vabbè di
stato fanno la fila del gioco però c'è
anche il gabibbo in miniatura qua del
basso a sinistra prete bellissimo per
favore vorrei il gioco completo questa
era una sorta di demo se fate il gioco
completo io lo compro la vita è questo
ciò che ho fatto anche molto bene
la dinamica pazzesca bellissimo grazie
per aver fatto è come si chiamava come
avete visto il vostro con fa vicenza a
fare la baby sitter quindi se avete
bisogno
faccio io mi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi
piacete la campanella e noi ci vediamo
come sempre hanno proseguito bello
ragazzi
[Musica]